leave the keys
you still do that thing leave the keys
we can offer our biggest discounts on 30
recycled and Ultra Premium laser okay
okay phone
yeah sure go ahead
let me talk to you about a few of the
other things we can offer namely we know
the tax season is coming up so by April
1st we can have you fully stocked one
discount prices on ink cartridges three
and also any forms that you're going to
need seven you can custom make them
and she's six months old
I appreciate what you guys are saying
but it makes more fiscal sense to go
with one of the big guys sure true we
can't compete with their prices but let
me ask you something how important to
you is customer service
it's one of the big guys been on hold
this whole time
and this is done in Mifflin
hey Kelly it's Jim
here's my card
got my cell number my pager number my
home number and my other pager number I
never take vacations I never get sick
and I don't celebrate any major holidays
all right I get it we gotta do
all right
hi Kelly screw you
excuse me there is no way to address a
superior oh yeah
oh
what was that all about you forgot her
birthday
it was yesterday
insist
basically after Phyllis blackmailed
Angela Michael asked them both to step
down from the party planning committee
because there was too much drama what he
said was easy there was a problem with
having one head of the party planning
committee she becomes too powerful so he
pointed two heads
humiliating
that's
on my side
so this is fun
are you kidding
I'm not done yet
wait this fits in the palm of my hand
you haven't blown them up enough
why have you chosen Brown and gray
balloons they match the carpet what is
that
it is your birthday period even a fact
not even an exclamation point this is
more professional it's not like she
discovered a cure for cancer I can't
believe I've had this looks
are you trying to hurt my feelings
because if so you are succeeding
fortunately my feelings regenerated
twice the speed of a normal Lance very
good then have you collected the money
from everyone I am working on it how
much do you have
six dollars
that's how much you and I contributed
damn it Jim
I said I was working on
we have to write my suggestions down too
I'm not writing horse hunt
I don't even know what that means it's
in the name
okay so far
our Ideal Party consists of beer fights
to the death cupcakes blood pudding
blood touch football mating charades and
yes horse hunting you're right forget
horse hunting it's stupid is there a
birthday that you remember that you
loved
here's one
it was dark warm wet
a sudden burst of light an intense
pressure like I'd never felt before
father dressed in white pulls me forward
mother bites the cord okay stop
forever stop that story that's
disgusting and it doesn't count so give
me another one should celebrate
birthdays idiot it started as a
depression-era practicality and then
moved on to an awesome tradition that I
look forward to every year
what about you actually when I was seven
my dad took me to the Natural History
Museum New York
we looked at fossils all day at the end
of the day he got me a little plastic
Triceratops it was awesome
it's cool hey you know what's even
cooler than Triceratops
every other dinosaur that ever existed
Jim you know it'll be really dastardly
If We snuck out of here and got to The
Client First
mm-hmm
he's running
damn it
what what is this supposed to be it's a
monkey
Jim get real this is not a monkey it's
got a hula skirt and a blue nose hold on
hold on is this him what is that him
do something get out what what am I
gonna do I don't go slashes Tire
go get his hood
that's it oh that's great that's like a
five second delay it's white go
does this thing have turbo nitrous hit
the nas Nas
you mean like in Fast and Furious yeah
oh yeah definitely have not hit the nas
are you sure yes brace yourself three
two go one here we go
ready go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go
foreign
yeah you're an exec a Pennsylvania solar
Tech that sounds fake I told you you're
an exec at Stark Industries inspiration
you inherited from your father here's
the story they need Meredith somewhere
else ASAP okay so you're taking over you
just gotta get her out of there as soon
as you can all right I can do that then
what then make him to you you
gotta see what he's got exactly okay
remember this you're not gay stop it
it's gonna be great listen if anything
else happens just roll with it
Meredith oh I uh well this
this hola guitar
uh Manuel cleano El window
because we got
so this hot chocolate thing new business
well you know you can't actually poison
them right it isn't poison it's a
laxative people take laxatives all the
time this is just a lot more of a
laxative let me handle it
I really think we should join forces on
this one really what do we think what
would drive him crazy
I know here we go
Pepto-Bismol in his hot chocolate I've
got to stop with the hot chocolate stuff
I was thinking maybe we could Jam his
drawers so they only come out two inches
and then that way you can see everything
in them but you can't get it does Edgar
Allan Poe know about that one so
sinister
that wouldn't annoy a person at all were
you where do you come up with this stuff
okay all right well this isn't my best
but call froggy101 say that we're the
tour manager for Justin Bieber and we're
giving away free tickets we give them a
number to call for the tickets and it's
his number who is Justice beaver
it's a crime fighting beaver
absolutely now when you get down there
Joe's a little bit uh forgetful so she
may have locked the gate but what you're
going to do is go ahead and hop it and
just head back to the pool
it is weird look at you perceptive now I
know why Joe's kept her eye on you
and you make sure to get down there
check out the Harry Potter World
whatever you want to do in your spare
time is up to you Harry Potter world is
supposed to be fantastic apparently as
soon as corporate found out I wanted to
come in off the road Joe offered me a
cushy new job in Tallahassee and here's
the best part I'm a huge alligator nerd
I can name you every genus every
subspecies
also I'm a huge boob nerd check it out
and put her beer on us
you can't bring those swimming trunks
bye now bye I cannot believe this you're
sending Packer to Florida why you're
using it from my desk okay so you're
tricking him into flying to Florida this
wasn't my first choice Jim had so many
better ideas you have to tell him you've
sell them what you did no no no no no no
no no no no that that is not in the plan
that is actually anti what we're doing
he is my oldest friend I am going to
tell him wait why don't we come up with
a plan that we're all happy about